herr laschet deutschland diskutiert seit
tagen über den saustall turniers weit
über 1500 corona fälle schon wann haben
sie das letzte mal kontakt gehabt mit
herrn tennis und wie nahe stehen sie
sich na ja das ist schon länger her
ich habe ihn bei unterschiedlichen
gelegenheiten hier im lande getroffen
aber jetzt während der krise nicht da
kommt es darauf an dass die behörden
ordnungsgemäß mit dem unternehmen
sprechen fehler aufdecken beweise
sichern und vor allem über konsequenzen
nachdenken
haben sie mal versucht ihn telefonisch
zu erreichen um mit ihm klartext zu
sprechen
nein das ist finde ich muss man auch
sauber trennen der vorgang der hier
stattgefunden hat braucht eine klare
überprüfung durch die behörden gab es
verstöße gegen gesetze gab es verstöße
gegen arbeitsschutzvorschriften gab es
verstöße gegen die schutzverordnung rund
um die krone pandemie wir haben ja vor
einigen wochen alle betriebe in
nordrhein-westfalen 20.000 mit 20.000
tests die mitarbeiter auf gerona
getestet auch im betrieb die es damals
gab es keine vorfälle und man muss jetzt
aufklären was ist eigentlich seither
passiert und das ist eine sache der
zuständigen behörden
ich finde nicht dass man das am telefon
persönlich klärt da gilt klare
staatliche verantwortung aber dennoch
stellt sich hier ja auch die schuldfrage
wer ist daran schuld
was dort passiert ist jetzt hat
arbeitsminister hubertus heil gesagt
dass turniers persönlich haften sollte
sehen sie das genauso
das ist eine rechtsfrage wer da wie
haftet wer sich etwas verschulden zu
schulden hat kommen lassen das muss in
einem rechtsstaat immer aufgeklärt
werden wir haben über das wochenende
beweise sichern lassen auch in der
schlachterei selbst der betrieb ist
geschlossen und ich finde wir sollten
das den dafür zuständigen rechtsorganen
jetzt überlassen und das was mich im
moment beschäftigt
ist wie können wir möglichst schnell
klarheit für die menschen im kreis
gütersloh schaffen
die juristische aufarbeitung die wird
folgen aber jetzt ist krisenbewältigung
erforderlich hier sind konkrete
maßnahmen für die menschen erforderlich
und das andere wird folgen
aber das steht auch für sie persönlich
sie müssen doch verdammt wütend sein
auch wenn tennis
na ja klar ist man wütend aber wut ist
in der politik selten eine kategorie
mich ärgert es dass im ganzen land
nordrhein westfalen die infektionszahlen
sinken wir viele kreise haben die im
moment die krisenstäbe zurückfahren weil
es kaum ein neue infektionen gibt auch
der kreis gütersloh stand bis zu diesem
fall in der fabrik tennis sehr gut da
unter den deutschen kreisen und deshalb
ärgert einen des maßlos wenn dann ein
solcher vorfall die arbeit von vielen
vielen menschen zunichte macht aber in
der krise muss man dann handeln muss man
sehen wie können wir die quarantäne
sichern für 2.000 mitarbeiter wie können
wir übrigens auch die menschen anständig
in dieser quarantäne behandeln sie
wissen manche wohnblocks sind sogar
abgezäunt da kommt für mich darauf an
dass dolmetscher da sind die erklären
was passiert hier gerade die die
bedeutung der quarantäne für die
gesundheit erklären die eine versorgung
der menschen sicherstellen das ist der
eine wichtige teil und der andere ist
die menschen im kreis gütersloh wo es
ganz geringe infektionszahlen überhaupt
gibt die möglichst schnell umfassend zu
testen und das ist unser schwerpunkt der
nächsten tage ist herr turniers jetzt
schuld dass menschen aus dem kreis
gütersloh wie aussätzige behandelt
werden naja im kreis gütersloh empfinden
die menschen dass sie sagen dieser eine
vorfall bringt unseren ganzen kreis in
verruf und deshalb ist auch hoeneß in
der pflicht den schaden
wiedergutzumachen und daran mit
dass solche zustände jetzt endgültig
abgestellt werden wobei ich dazu sagen
muss alleine auf verabredungen kann man
das nicht akzeptieren wir brauchen klare
bundesgesetze bundesminister heil hat
dazu eckpunkte im bundeskabinett
vorgelegt er hat die volle rückendeckung
der landesregierung von
nordrhein-westfalen und mitreden ist
jetzt schluss wir brauchen jetzt
staatliche rechtliche gesetzliche
konsequenzen dass sich diese zustände
verändern und dass wir auch in der
fleischindustrie in zukunft klare regeln
durchsetzen
fordern sie die rücknahme von
übernachtungs verboten für diese
menschen die rücknahme von ausweisungen
von urlaubern aus gütersloh passiert an
der ostsee also ich glaube da brauchen
wir eine bundeseinheitliche
verständigung wie wir damit umgehen und
das wird in den nächsten tagen mit den
chefs der staatskanzlei und dem chef des
bundeskanzleramtes des erörtert ich habe
ja gestern mit markus söder gesprochen
ich verstehe die urlaubsregionen dass
die klarheit haben wollen die haben ja
auch ihre gesetze schon vorher gehabt
aber ich werbe auch dafür dass die
menschen die sich haben testen lassen
und die nachweisen können dass sie das
virus nicht tragen dass die auch die
möglichkeit haben den urlaub zu gehen
jetzt nach israelischer hat so lange
plant kann das natürlich machen
im nächsten atemzug riefen sie aber die
bürger dazu auf jetzt nicht aus dem
kreis heraus in andere kreise zu fahren
wie passt das denn zusammen
das eine ist ja die frage wie bewegt man
sich im moment im kreis das kann auch
nur ein appell sein wenn sie sich
erinnern als wir den lockdown hatten
hatten wir auch viele ausnahmen für
menschen die zu einem arbeitsplatz
mussten die in der kritischen
infrastruktur arbeiten und in einem
kreis der 330.000 einwohner hat in
nordrhein westfalen sind die kreise sehr
groß
da wird man den menschen nicht verbieten
können dass ich zur arbeit fahren
beispielsweise nach bielefeld oder
andere städte aber wir können
sicherstellen dass wir sie vorher testen
und wir haben gleichzeitig große
unternehmen im kreis gütersloh
bertelsmann wo andere aus anderen
kreisen einpendeln und dort arbeiten um
die müssten sie sich ja dann auch
kümmern also eine reine insellage eines
kreises ist nicht machbar
aber es soll niemand jetzt ins
fitnessstudio ins schwimmbad oder zu
anderen einrichtungen fahren tourismus
der direkt im umfeld stattfindet
freizeitgestaltung darauf kann man
verzichten und wer in urlaub reisen will
dem gebe ich den dringenden hinweis
lassen sie sich testen wir werden in
jeder gemeinde in diesem großen kreis
jetzt teststationen errichten
wir bündeln dass jetzt auch hier in der
landesregierung die bundeswehr wird noch
einmal ihr personal aufstocken so dass
wir wirklich viele viele tausende tests
am ende der woche haben werden und dann
haben wir auch ein klares lagebild sind
ist eigentlich die menschen im kreis
gütersloh oder ist es auf den betrieb
turniers beschränkt das kann im moment
keiner beantworten
das geht nur indem man fakten prüft und
sicherstellt es gibt jetzt selbst
internationale reaktionen österreich hat
eine reisewarnung für gesamt nrw
ausgesprochen ist das verhältnismäßig
also wir tun jetzt mal erst alles dass
wir die zahlen so kriege dass diese
reisewarnung bald wieder aufgehoben
werden kann als in ischgl mal etwas
passiert ist haben wir nicht eine
reisewarnung für ganz österreich
aber es führt dass es schlimmer eins ist
nein das glaube ich nicht weil sie haben
in gütersloh
nach stand jetzt eine beschränkung auf
den betrieb das wissen wir und die
menschen sind alle in quarantäne
von da kann keine weiterverbreitung der
stattfinden und die polizei sichert mit
drei hundertschaften diese quarantäne
das ist der eine unterschied zu ischgl
wir wissen wo die infizierten sind und
halten sie in quarantäne und der zweite
unterschied ist dass wir jetzt prüfen
wie weit ist es im kreis gütersloh
verbreitet und wenn das ergebnis
geringen wäre dann kann man es auch
überhaupt keinen fall vergleichen ich
will war party war alkohol war enge und
das hat sich quer über europa verbreitet
hier ist es eine bestimmte gruppe von
beschäftigten die das opfer geworden
sind von zuständen wie in der
fleischindustrie herrschen und den
menschen helfen wer humanitär und
begrenzen aber deren bewegung
dennoch gibt es massive kritik auch an
ihn an der kritik als krisenmanager
sozusagen haben sie den lockdown viel zu
spät verkündet nein wir haben ihn ja
letzte woche verkündet für schulen und
kindertagesstätten das war ganz am
anfang der entwicklung und das war
parallel zu dem was wir ja auch auf der
bundesebene im märz gemacht haben wir
mit schulen und kitas begonnen haben
dann die fakten über das wochenende
geprüft sie wissen wir haben ja nicht
einmal gewusst wo die arbeitnehmer
wohnen wir haben um 31 in der nacht die
akten gesichert damit wir die namen und
adressen der beschäftigten haben das war
die erste priorität da habe ich selbst
vor ort einen besuch im krisenstab
gemacht mit den experten des robert koch
instituts mit dem gesundheitsamt
gesprochen und dann haben wir die zweite
stufe gezündet das ist eine aus meiner
sicht richtige reihenfolge weil wir
gleichzeitig quarantäne sichern mussten
und unterschiedliche stufen des lockdown
zunächst aber die kritik die geäußert
wird geht ja in ihre richtung auch
deshalb weil man sagt sie stehen
sozusagen für die lockerung in der
öffentlichkeit fiel es ihnen deshalb so
schwer jetzt zurückzukommen zumindest im
regionalen doktor nein das fiel mir
überhaupt nicht schwer weil ich immer
gesagt habe da wo wir öffnen können wo
wir menschen grundrechte zurückgeben
können
da müssen wir es tun wenn es vertretbar
ist und die öffnungen die wir gehabt
haben waren vertretbar weil mit jeder
weiteren öffnung trotzdem die
infektionszahlen überall im land zurück
gegangen ist und dem weg sind ja
inzwischen alle deutschen länder gefolgt
der betrieb tönnies war auch im
striktesten lockdown im märz offen weil
natürlich die lebensmittelversorgung der
menschen auch in dieser zeit gesichert
werden sollte und deshalb finde ich wenn
man öffnen kann soll man es tun wenn es
ein risiko gibt muss man auch in
konsequenz handeln und öffnungen
zurücknehmen und wir haben lokalisierbar
ereignisse in ganz deutschland gehabt in
flüchtlingsunterkünften auf spargel
höfen in altenheimen auch in fleisch
betrieben aber kein einziger kreis in
deutschland hat komplett die öffnungen
zurückgenommen und den zustand des lok
downs wieder hergestellt insofern ist
das was wir jetzt in gütersloh machen
und in warendorf machen eine eine
situation wo wir die ersten sind die so
konsequent in deutschland handeln und
ich vermute dass wir noch weitere fälle
auch in anderen teilen gekommen und da
kann der das was wir jetzt versuchen ein
muster sein kommentiert wird auch das
durch ihr vorgehen jetzt hier in nrw
durch die kritik auch ihre kanzler
träume in gefahr sind stimmt das das
weiß ich nicht die habe ich jedenfalls
derzeit nicht wenn sie morgens aufstehen
und sich mit gütersloh und tennis und
infektionen beschäftigen und den ganzen
tag nur mit den krisenstäben in kontakt
stehen und abends wenn sie ins bett
gehen sie wieder daran denken wie wir
die pandemie bekämpfen dann ist für
solche träume keine zeit wir
konzentrieren uns jetzt auf die
bekämpfung der pandemie und der unions
wettbewerb oder was immer da im moment
spekuliert wird spielt für mich derzeit
keine rolle wir müssen diese krise jetzt
bewältigen
aber wenn sie jetzt zum beispiel sagen
würde ich will zwar weiterhin
cdu-vorsitzender werden würde mich aber
freuen wenn markus söder kanzlerkandidat
würde bekämen sie wahrscheinlich
das weiß ich nicht ich sage nochmal wir
beschäftigen uns mit der krise mit
corona mitmenschen in quarantäne die im
moment auch andere sorgen haben als
solche spekulationen und insofern gibt
es nicht mal den gedanken an das was sie
gerade beschreiben herzlichen dank
ministerpräsident armin laschet für das
gespräch